[Applaudissements]
je leur laisse une chance par semaine
une chance par semaine voilà c'est leur
sens je leur laisse une chance par
semaine de prendre des décisions voilà
voilà là ils ont pris celle-ci j'ai dit
d'accord je vous fais plaisir on va le
faire Tarek c'est monté sauvé Elodie
pour la peine il pourra vraiment faire
exactement on va vraiment de voir parce
que les pauvres voilà Élodie toi c'est
un massage à la bougie d'une heure en
solo que je t'ai réservé ton alibi c'est
ton mari est jaloux il ne veut pas que
quelqu'un te touche avec les mains
n'importe qui
honneur philippe est un ami c'est la
famille t'inquiète pas alors je peux te
dire c'est parti je rappelle à noter les
spectateurs qui nous rejoignent
je ne sens pas du tout cette séquence
je rappelle
oui bonjour je vous appelle parce que
j'ai pris rendez-vous pour un massage
[Musique]
prochainement voilà il faudrait que je
retourne dans mon agenda je me souviens
plus du jour de mon rendez-vous au nom
de fondants
ton massage
j'ai pris un massage au nom d'Élodie
Fontan je sais pas si l'on retrouvait
sur l'agenda mais en fait je vais être
obligé de l'annuler je suis vraiment
désolée parce que j'en ai parlé à mon
conjoint personne qui te touche bah
voilà je voulais dire
mais en fait il accepte pas que j'aille
faire un massage dans un institut qui
connaît pas
que quelqu'un il veut pas qu'une
personne me touche avec ses mains à
moins qu'elle me le fasse avec ses pieds
mais c'est un peu plus compliqué
madame c'est le mari là
c'est Francis
ça va être une femme qui va la masser
c'est qui
que des femmes non elle lui touche pas
comme ça
[Musique]
mais peut-être que je pourrais voir
la semaine prochaine que cette semaine
comprenez
donc ça c'est des problèmes que vous
devez régler vous-même avec votre mari
de venir dans votre institut et on m'a
dit que du bien
madame madame madame madame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est en direct on est en direct vous
êtes en direct à la télé c'est Cyril
Hanouna
[Musique]
mais pourquoi tu fais des animations de
1990 genre tu sais comme dans une
surprise ouais c'est génial laisse-moi
parler avec la main
oui madame oui madame
pourquoi il pleut pourquoi tu fais ça
je vous l'avais dit que cette séquence
je la sentais pas du tout
le problème qu'on a on va pas se mentir
c'est que même on passe un coup de fil
on a l'impression qu'on passe un coup de
fil mais très très loin c'est le
problème c'est le problème
on est prêt sur Fifi non mais lâchez-le
on vient on vient de vivre de drame
Fifi tu veux vraiment le faire
alors
un jacuzzi rien que pour toi pendant une
heure en fait tu étais allergique aux
chlore c'est devant le mec
excuse-moi je suis français dans ton
émission de samedi
merci
j'ai réservé un
jacuzzi jacuzzi au nom de Philippe
Lachaud
et en fait j'ai un petit problème c'est
que il y a du chlore dedans non il y a
pas de cœur ah il y a pas de cœur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
18h
c'est tellement éclaté au sol
dans un restaurant italien
dis ce que tu veux je pense
merci Elodie heureusement que tu es là
bonjour et je vous appelle parce que
j'ai réservé un une table pour demain au
nom de Julien Rutti et en fait je vais
pas pouvoir venir enfin quoi que si
peut-être est-ce que vous faites des
sushis
allô est-ce qu'on fait des sushis
restaurant italien pourquoi vous pouvez
pas venir
en fait parce que je voulais manger des
sushis vous pourriez me servir des
sushis ou pas
de de beignets des mozza si vous aimez
ça est-ce qu'on rouler comme les sushis
si vous avez vraiment
[Musique]
vous savez qui est Julien Rutti
je les connais
c'est mon père
Monsieur monsieur en fait on est en
direct à la télévision c'est quoi le nom
de votre le nom de votre resto
mais j'ai moi j'ai répondu sushi mais je
vais recevoir une spécialité italienne
et il vient d'inviter tout le public
dans ton restaurant
vous êtes les bienvenus
des petits problèmes en ce moment
[Rires]
on se parle après mon chéri avec plaisir
merci en tout cas on t'embrasse et merci
d'avoir participé à cette séquence avec
plaisir merci mon chéri